this is a pledge that I intend to keep
if the house votes tonight for an early
general election my tenure as Speaker
and MP will end when this Parliament
ends if the house does not so vote I
have concluded that the least disruptive
and most democratic course of action
would be for me to stand down at the
close of business on Thursday October
the 31st
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
least disruptive because that date will
fall shortly after the votes on the
Queen's speech expected on 21st and 22nd
October the week or so after that maybe
quite lively and it would be best to
have an experienced figure in the chair
[Applause]
for that short period most Democratic
because it will mean that a ballot is
held when all members have some
knowledge of the candidates this is far
preferable to a contest at the beginning
of a parliament when new MPs will not be
similarly informed and may find
themselves vulnerable to undue
institutional influence
[Applause]
[Music]
we would not want anyone to be whipped
senseless would we throughout my time as
Speaker I have sought to increase the
relative authority of this legislature
for which I will make absolutely no
apology to anyone
[Music]
[Applause]
anywhere at any time to deploy a perhaps
dangerous phrase I have also sought to
be the backbenchers backstop
I could not do so without the support of
a small but superb team in speakers
house the wider house staff my
Buckingham constituents and above all my
wife Sally and our three children
Oliver Freddie and Jemima
[Applause]
from the bottom of my heart I thank them
all profusely
I could also not have served without the
repeated support of this house and its
members past and present this is a
wonderful place filled with memory by
people who are motivated by their notion
of the national interest by their
perception of the public good and by
their duty not as delegates but as
representatives
to do what they believe is right for our
country we degrade this Parliament at
our peril
I have served as a member of parliament
for 22 years and for the last 10 as
Speaker this has been let me put it
explicitly the greatest privilege and
honor of my professional life for which
I will be eternally grateful I wish my
successor in the chair the very best
fortune in standing up for the rights of
honorable and right honourable members
individually and for Parliament
institutionally as the Speaker of the
House of Commons thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]